so the details of this incident are
still emerging but what we do know is
the police were called at 1 29 pm today
to reports of a shooting close to
Phoenix road which is pretty Central a
bit north in London close to Houston
Station and there they say they found
three women who were taken to a central
London Hospital now their ages are 41 48
and 54 London ambulance servers and the
London air as ambulance also attended
now the women's injuries are not
life-threatening the police says however
for the 48 year old they may be life
changing now at 205 PM the police were
told that a seven-year-old girl was also
taken to a central London Hospital with
injuries that are believed to have been
sustained in the same incident now we
don't know her condition we'll wait to
hear we also are not 100 sure who took
her to the hospital but what we do know
is that the police tells us that the
incident took place close to a church
where a funeral was taking place and it
is believed that our shops were fired
for a from a moving car that then sped
away from the scene there have been no
arrests as of yet but of course a huge
police presence in this area which is a
very Central Area a stone's throw from
Houston Station one of the busiest Rail
stations in London very close to a very
busy road it would have been quite
populated on a Friday afternoon a
terrifying incident for anyone who would
have been nearby of course terrifying
for those who were attending that
funeral in that church so no rest as of
yet investigation continues but a very
disturbing incident and we are wait to
hear the condition of the seven-year-old
who's been injured